so what happens to cnn without chris
cuomo well here is exclusive footage
this show has just obtained of the dwarf
king and his minions including don lemon
putting chris cuomo in a shallow grave
again these images are just into our
news department
of course no one is going to be hit
harder by today's news than cuomo's best
on-air friend don lemon we'll probably
never see moments like this again on
national television
people have been asking me what are you
going to give chris for valentine's day
and so here it is chris i have a card
for you
oh and there you go it's beautiful
i knew you would think it was beautiful
because you're surrounded you didn't
want to put your face in here why it
wouldn't fit because that would be like
me loving myself that's what you're
about first of all can we just for the
sake of valentine's day can we stop this
projection of where i am the one who's
so into myself
looking at moments like that you no
longer really feel that sorry for chris
cuomo
assuming he can get a job or he's saved
enough to live at least he won't have to
do that again
vince collins is a radio host in the
city of washington we're always happy to
have him join us tonight vince what do
you make of this
well boy i tell you i i think i figured
out why chris cuomo lifts so much is
because he was the only guy carrying
that network's ratings as small as those
ratings were the reality is chris cuomo
was the only draw that that network has
had i mean think about this cnn once had
a legendary status as being the type of
place where you could turn to for news
that's gone that's been gone for many
years now the last big star on the
network was larry king they tried making
anderson cooper the face of the network
they gave him multiple hours during
prime time that didn't work so in 2018
they turned to their morning guy chris
coleman they said please do something
and he was the best that they could come
up with as jason whitlock said the
typical american meathead was about the
only thing that was actually getting an
audience and that's why when you just
played that don lemon clip that was
happening every night the reason that
was happening is because don lemon can't
get ratings on his own they had to have
15 minute handoffs with chris cuomo just
to get people to tune in to something
else on the network this is going to be
a big problem for cnn going forward
that's such a good point i mean
admittedly being the highest rated
anchor on cnn really is being like the
best caterer in uzbekistan i mean it's a
it's a relative measure but i mean he
was number one and they fired the number
one guy because the atlantic magazine
told them to
what does that what does that tell you
isn't this supposed to be a business i
mean isn't right you think of this as a
business where
you know the outcome is measurable the
guy with the highest ratings but didn't
matter
yeah exactly and what happens is now is
that this is kind of it's kind of a good
tell for like what our rolling class is
interested in like the elites are very
insular they don't actually care what
the average audience member is
interested in they don't care that the
way you probably have watched cnn
through the last few years has been you
accidentally bumped into it at an
airport it's not about that it's about
what are their friends at the new york
times thing the second the new york
times in the atlantic turned against
chris cuomo chris cuomo was thrown off
the ship this is it's a these are people
who do not care about the average
american they care more about the people
they're going to encounter at lunch
probably at a place that i can't afford
imagine working for a company in which
your boss cares what the atlantic
magazine thinks i mean that's
it it is it's beyond i imagine knowing
someone who cares with the atlantic
magazine things who reads the new york
times and takes it seriously oh find new
friends speaking of something you only
bump into at an airport yeah thank you
it's totally right vince collins great
to see you tonight thank you
nice to see you tucker hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else